libya's rival military committees have
been meeting
in the city of sirte for the last three
days
the meetings facilitated by the u.n have
played a critical role
in the success of this week's talks in
switzerland
a nationwide ceasefire was agreed last
october in geneva
which stipulated that all foreign
fighters should leave the country within
three months
but the fighters have failed to withdraw
by the january 24th
deadline and the deal also called for
the main roads between eastern and
western libya to reopen
a member of the joint military committee
says that will happen
once they remove land mines from the
area
we agreed on opening the road between
east and west and we've agreed to start
the process of clearing minds through
the specialist teams that will start
their work on february 10th and end on
february 25th
the un security council has requested
the secretary general to establish and
deploy a team to libya to monitor the
ceasefire
essential that all foreign fighters and
mercenaries
move first to tripoli and benghazi and
then leave the country
according to the new schedule that was
defined
and it is essential that everybody
cooperates with the new authorities to
make peace happen
in libya according to the u.n support
mission there are more than 20 000
foreign fighters in libya
with an estimated two thousand russian
mercenaries
moscow was one of warlord khalifa
hafter's biggest supporters
in his 14-month failed military campaign
to take control of the capital tripoli
the u.s
africa command has said russia flew
fourth generation jet fighters into
libya
with neither hafters forces nor private
military companies
having the ability to arm operate and
sustain the jets
without state support the jets are
believed to be based in the el jafra air
base
in central libya
we agreed to send a letter to the
security council demanding that
countries that have mercenaries and
forces on the ground
must be removed immediately on friday
libya's rival factions agreed to form a
new transitional government
that will lead the country until
elections in december
libya's new unified government has
received international praise and
support
but the road ahead is filled with many
challenges
forcing foreign fighters out of the
country will perhaps be the most
daunting task
but without doing that it could be
difficult to hold a nationwide election
come december malak trainer al jazeera
tripoli